the solar system is the area of space
that has been investigated by mankind
most
people have been observing the planets
satellites and other celestial bodies in
the space around the sun for hundreds of
years
thanks to their efforts the space
objects lying closest to us have been
studied comparatively well
but as for areas beyond neptune's orbit
there are thousands of equally
interesting celestial bodies hiding in
the forbidding and freezing dark and
each of them keeps its own secrets to
itself
one of these dark sullen worlds doggedly
following their orbit is kwawa
and that is the object we will talk
about today
the beginning of the 21st century
heralded a whole bunch of sensational
discoveries in astronomy
a number of objects close to pluto in
terms of their size were detected one
after another in remote areas of the
solar system
one of the first objects to be spotted
was kwawa
the discovery was made by chadwick
trujillo and michael brown in 2002 while
there were studying images of the star
sky taken in palomar observatory
at first the detected object was thought
to be slightly smaller than pluto
but after double checking the planetoid
turned out to be much smaller
still this celestial body remains one of
the top 10 largest bodies in the kuiper
belt
this area in space looks like a
remarkably wide ring encompassing the
solar system beyond neptune's orbit to
give you an idea of its size here are
its basic parameters its inner radius
measures approximately 30 astronomical
units with its outer radius roughly 55
astronomical units apart from a number
of small objects there are several
relatively large dwarf planets to be
found here pluto aerys makimaki and
others
koawa is one of these too now let's talk
about it in more detail
this celestial body looks like a
flattened ellipsoid its equatorial
diameter measures about a thousand one
hundred and thirty eight kilometers and
the distance between its poles is one
thousand and thirty kilometers or so
this makes kwawa's diameter about twice
as small as pluto's with sharon just
barely beating it in terms of size
[Music]
kwawa's mass is estimated at around 1.4
times 10 to the power of 21 kilograms
which makes it around 10 times lighter
than pluto
quawer's average density is
approximately 2200 kilograms per cubic
meter
which is typical of dwarf planets
the planetoid is thought to be made up
of mostly rocks and water vapor
just like other objects in the kuiper
belt
estimates show the intensity of
radioactive decay in koala's interior to
be too low to melt the lower layers of
ice that is why in all likelihood there
is no subsurface ocean under the ice
shell on this planetoid
now let's see how freezing cold it is on
kwawang its average surface temperature
is predictably low at approximately 44
kelvin or
229 degrees celsius below zero
even at temperatures this low
frozen gases in the vacuum of space
gradually vaporize
and form a remarkably rarified
atmosphere that is made up mostly of
methane
however the density of the planetoid's
atmosphere is at least 100 million times
lower than that of the earth
kwawa is known to be a rather dark
celestial body reflecting from 10 to 20
percent of all light shed on it it has a
reddish hue
just like many other celestial objects
in those areas of space
this color comes from impurities
containing tholins complex polymers
originating in frozen methane when it is
exposed to ultraviolet rays still it is
assumed that kwawa contains considerably
less ice and frozen gases than larger
transneptunian objects mostly on account
of its more modest dimensions and a
weaker gravity
the free-fall acceleration on kwawa's
surface is estimated at a measly 0.29
meters per square second which is about
33 times slower than on our planet
this means that when hypothetically
placed on the planetoid surface a human
would weigh just 2 or 3 kilos
investigations and observations show the
surface of the object to contain
crystalline water ice
however the detected modification of ice
may form only at temperatures not lower
than 110 kelvin or
163 degrees celsius below zero which is
at least 66 kelvin higher than the
current average temperature on the
planetide
according to one of the hypotheses as to
this discrepancy the detected ice may
have formed in the dwarf planet's
interior where the temperatures are
higher on account of radioactive decay
of heavy elements
the ice probably got ejected as a result
of cryo-volcanic activity and so spilled
out on the surface
another hypothesis claims the anomalous
ice to have appeared on a planetoid as a
result of meteorite bombardment
spectral analyses reveal kwawa to
contain small amounts of solidified
methane and ethane although here their
concentration is considerably lower than
on the surfaces of other larger
transneptunian objects
by slowly evaporating frozen
hydrocarbons replenish qawa's atmosphere
although the planetoid's gravity isn't
strong enough to keep the gas molecules
close to the surface thus kwawa is
slowly but surely getting stripped of
its atmosphere and in billions of years
time will lose it completely
like most celestial objects the
planetoid rotates on its axis
the rotation period hasn't been gauged
exactly yet but judging by its
luminosity which repeatedly changes
following a certain pattern it is
estimated at roughly 18 hours
kwawa follows an almost circular orbit
around the sun which takes it slightly
less than 289 years to complete
the orbit eccentricity is just .04 which
is two and a half times more than that
of our earth and twice as small as that
of mars
it takes sunlight about five hours to
reach qawa's surface
it has been calculated that the
planetoid last reached its ophelia in
1932 with a distance to the center of
our system approximately 45 astronomical
units
now kuawa is on its way to its orbit's
perihelion
which is estimated to be reached in
about 2075.
the distance between the planetoid and
the sun will be 42 astronomical units at
that point
[Music]
its orbit doesn't allow kwawa to
approach neptune closely enough to
experience this planet's gravity pole
such like space objects are referred to
as kubiwanos and kuawa is a typical
representative of this class alongside
varuna and makimaki
kwawa's orbit is tilted to the ecliptic
plane at an angle of 8 degrees
and this fact leads scientists to
believe it to confirm that neptune did
have some gravitational influence on the
dwarf planet a long while ago
currently kwawar is known to have only
one satellite
dubbed wayward it was detected in 2006.
this small astronomical body follows a
moderately elongated orbit around the
planetoid
it's aphelion is estimated at
approximately 16 and a half thousand
kilometers
in its perihelion whey what is anything
from twelve thousand to thirteen
thousand kilometers away from the
surface of the dwarf planet
the satellite completes a full orbit
around kwawa roughly every 12 and a half
days
to date its orbit's other parameters
haven't been gauged with any degree of
certainty yet
wheyward's diameter measures around 170
kilometers
assuming the dwarf planet and its
satellite are similar in terms of their
makeup weiwat should be two thousand
times lighter
the gravity of an object this light is
not enough to make it spherical
this must be the reason why wayward
shape is irregular just like that of
most other asteroids and small
astronomical bodies in the solar system
taking into account the current stage of
space technology's development it is
estimated that it would take a space
probe slightly over 13 and a half years
to reach kwawa
to date only the new horizons probe has
approached it closest in 2016 it took a
number of images of kwawa from a
distance of 14 astronomical units
it is known that astronomers in the us
and china considered an option of
sending an automatic space probe to
remote objects of the solar system
and kwawa was on the list of potential
objects of interest
still so far there were no official
announcements and confirmations as to
planned scientific missions there
and so just like countless other worlds
out there kwawa is still waiting for its
pioneers
[Music]
dear friends if there is an object in
space you are particularly interested in
but we haven't made a video about it yet
feel free to tell us which one it is in
the comments if you enjoyed this video
we'd be happy if you hit the like button
and subscribed if you still haven't done
so
we in our turn will do our best to
produce new exciting and informative
videos let's keep in touch
[Music]
you